Many apps use audio to create fantastic experiences
Whether it's a disc, karaoke or music game
Audio is a powerful tool for expression, entertainment and creativity
Today I will show you the oboe program, a new C++ music library.
How to simply create on Android
A fun, interactive audio experience.
But first, what do we mean by interactive audio?
Imagine this is the keyboard
When I press a button, I will immediately send a sound file.
This makes people feel that the keyboard response is very agile.
Because I will get a voice feedback right away.
This is why playing an instrument
Is such a pleasant experience
But imagine, after knocking a key,
I have to wait a moment to hear the sound.
Such hysteresis or delay
Will make playing the keyboard very difficult and frustrating
Again, this also applies to apps and games.
Whether it's an app for rhythm games, karaoke, discs and scratches
Or virtual reality, synthesizer, drum machine,
And other virtual instruments
These applications share common requirements
They need low latency audio
To provide a great user experience
These are all that the oboe program can do.
This is a C++ repository that makes it available on specific Android devices.
Easier to get the lowest latency audio
Working in API version 16 and above
This means it is compatible with 99% of Android devices.
Under this range, cores with AAudio or API version 27 and above
Going back to OpenSL ES at all API levels will work
In this way, the oboe program provides a single, easy-to-use API.
This takes advantage of the new features
And let AAudio perform better.
It also provides all backup compatibility for the device.
Start using the oboe program, all you have to do is
Clone a repository from GitHub
This will copy the database to your local machine
The oboe program is designed to create CMake subprojects
In order to create it, you must update your CMake surface configuration
If you don't have an existing CMake configuration
You must pass the link below
Add C++ support to your app
First, tell your project where the source code of the oboe program is.
There should be a path to the repository you have cloned.
Next, add this path as a subdirectory
And add a public title
Finally, add the oboe program as a dependent library.
Let the Android studio index the database and enter the creation
Refresh link to C++ project
Now that you are done, you can join the oboe heading
Objects using the oboe program are in your code
All objects are in the namespace of the oboe program
So they won't and any other
The namespace you might use conflicts
Now you are ready to use the oboe API
View the getting started guide, code example
All code labs are available on the GitHub website below
Found on the link
If you have any problems or problems
Please post the issue in the problem area on our GitHub website
We will do our best to help you
You can learn more about the oboe program.
Including how to create low-latency audio streams
And high priority audio response
Create sound with the oboe program in the next video in this series
Come here today.
Good luck, let's get some sound out.